I was educated as a chemist I did my
undergraduate degree in chemistry and
the University of Science and Technology
of China and rung in 1998
I went to Harvard to conduct research in
a chemist Department to get my PhD
degree in 2002 I moved to University of
California Berkeley to do my postdoc
working on you know nanoparticles
materials electron transport 2005
h-honest type of faculty in material
science department that was the time in
2005 I started to get inches in the
battery research
2005 also that was a long time the
renewable energy becomes so important
clean energy is important in a solar
cell research are going very high so at
that time I was already thinking about
you know what's what's next and after
you get the clean energy you need to
store them and having a car burning
gasoline you you want to have a clean
energy such as battery source to of the
powder car that's how I got into the
battery area in 2005
my group study very a broad topic of
research including batteries solar cells
environmental technology and in a
biotechnology and also condom physics
I'm really passionate about batteries
it's really because it's potential and
for the society I currently have to
category of research going in the
various areas once I is to produce high
energy batteries for the portable
electronics and the electrical vehicles
through new materials design those
materials can have very high capacity
for stole EDM ions for example the
second category of research is for
finding new materials very low cost very
high power a very high energy efficiency
for the stationary large-scale storage
students of all
people you know looking industry if they
are interesting in in the batteries
interesting in material science part of
that certainly taking this battery
module will be the first right thing to
do in reading some of the basics of our
electrochemistry about the batteries is
necessary you know to get star and then
reading about the state of our research
you know reading about the past
development outlasted batteries lithium
ion batteries are also absolutely
necessary to to get to know what's
happening in the view
to develop a source of energy to power
everything in in my life that got to be
electricity yeah electricity you can
produce them claim you can store them
claim you can use them clean